on en vient à ces révélations de l'igas
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales sur les études concernant le
téléphone portable
dans leur rapport publié aujourd'hui les
enquêteurs s'interrogent sur
l'impartialité des experts qui ont été
chargés d'évaluer les risques sanitaires
liés au mobile
il avait conclu à l'absence d'effet
identifier et bien on apprend que
plusieurs de ses experts étaient
rémunérés par les industriels du secteur
ça fait désordre françois beaudonnet
france brisset les milliers d'antennes
relais et les 50 millions de téléphones
mobiles sont ils dangereux pour notre
santé
depuis des années les études officielles
prouve le contraire mais des
associations ont toujours remise en
cause l'objectivité de certains experts
qui les ont menés pour la première fois
un rapport lui aussi officielle va dans
leur sens ce rapport révèle la présence
d'au moins un scientifique avait un lien
direct c'est-à-dire financier rémunéré à
ce titre là par un opérateur et qui en
même temps était le président du groupe
de travail sur la téléphonie mobile et
deux autres scientifiques qui avait
délié indirectes c'est-à-dire que
l'ensemble des opérateurs financer leurs
labos
ce rapport a été rendu public sous la
pression de deux associations ils
critiquent l'aps l'agencé française de
sécurité sanitaire de l'environnement
il affirme que ses méthodes d'expertisé
présente des insuffisances au ministère
de la santé on affirme avoir déjà
amélioré le fonctionnement de lagence
mais on défend le système de choix des
experts de n'avoir comme expert que des
personnes qui n'ont absolument aucun
lien on risque fort de n'avoir ou pas
d'experts du tout et des experts qui en
fait un peu de compétences les
opérateurs n'ont pas souhaité répondre à
nos questions
ce rapport n'affirme pourtant pas que le
téléphone mobile est nocif pour la santé
mais il vient renforcer ceux qui se
battent pour plus de transparence